we were talking about technology and I
was talking about they they keep coming
out with updates on my phone I think of
myself as a pretty a competent guy and I
can't work my phone anymore cuz they
keep updating it are you good with that
I don't know what the why why don't they
get it how they like it before they send
it you know what I mean did they not
think of it before yes I have last but I
bought I took it home unwrapped it and
the first thing you said there's an
update I just bought it yeah I just they
said when you left the store we thought
of something we forgot but if you don't
you have ignore the update warnings but
if you don't they just pester you and
it's like it's just like a marriage on
the very last thread it's just a get
goes there's an update and they say okay
but not now and they go okay I'll remind
you later yeah okay just but not now
that's all yeah yeah yeah about tonight
tonight yeah fine tonight but not not
now yeah my main thing is not now hey
just want me to remind you to install it
I'm yeah it's not now my device is
bringing up as it's a neediness yes
there's a neediness from our devices
they're constantly whining and wanting
us to reset them and tend to them it's
not right yeah it's not right in our day
when we were kids
you bought a wind-up gramophone and it
played and it never updated another
complaint and you didn't complain about
it either
you were happy to have it yeah yes so I
guess so we share if we share that other
that we both were both pretending that
we were born in 1880
you